hey everybody and welcome to a
significant wild ride with stevo i'll be
gosh dang darned if this week's guest
isn't the single most culturally
significant person alive today i mean
it's steve wozniak he invented the
personal computer that smartphone in
your pocket is because of this man and i
am proud and honored to call steve
wozniak a personal friend of mine not
only was this episode significant it was
a lot of fun and it came out smooth just
like my shave and how do i get such a
clean smooth shave i get it from harry's
yeah and harry's believes you should
have the best
most comfortable closest shave and not
have to pay a ton of money for it so
yeah they make blades that stay sharp
longer than the competition and for a
far more reasonable price plus first
time customers
get this best deal from the wild ride
podcast and here it is okay
you're gonna get a weighted ergonomic
handle a five blade razor you're gonna
get a travel case to keep that razor
safe in your bag and you're gonna get
foaming shave gel that's a 13
value and the wild ride listeners get
their best offer which is you get all
that starter kit for just three bucks
jump on this man because you need this
product
so it's harrys.com
stevo for that starter kit with
everything i mentioned of a 13 value for
just three bucks get to harrys.com stevo
and enjoy being smooth like me and this
podcast
liquid death i saw you advertise that on
the show yeah they are they're mad at
plastic and and uh
instead that's the idea is it's death to
plastic
oh
oh this is so exciting
i'm very very excited about this
ladies and gentlemen steve wozniak
yeah
so good to see you bro
great to see you again yeah always yeah
always great to see you and i think that
a lot of people would consider uh us to
be an unlikely
uh friendship
not not people who know me right anybody
anybody and i love right i love you
i i love you so much
and uh
we met in 2009 when we were on dancing
with the stars
i don't even remember years i don't do
years
i don't do years sometime in the past
okay steve does years days months he
remembers days oh i have friends that
can remember you know every event at
apple for example right to the exact
week and the day of what we did this on
wednesday
i don't know how they do it and some
people remember names and faces but i
have a disease called prosopagnosia 150
people have it and i can't recognize
faces
oh wow yeah what do you recognize
voices voices i can recognize stories
things we did i remember all that
and uh just every face is kind of the
same even janet's i make mistake both
directions wow wow
i remember the time i was in saudi
arabia and they had this mess on you
could only see the eyes but i could tell
it was janet's eyes so i squeezed her
butt and it wasn't janet
that's great
just a joke just did you yeah
every comedian you know has to kind of
the rules rules don't matter that much
guys i love it i i love it and um steve
has a co-host blindness where he doesn't
introduce me or paul sometimes
well i mean you've met scott randolph
and and this is the gorgeous paul
briskey it's a pleasure to meet you
steve yeah yeah great yeah great to be
here i wish we could do this more often
man and i watched your show and said oh
gosh i want to be there place to tell
you know interesting stories a little
out of the normal yeah absolutely and um
what an honor to be able to do this with
you i just learned that the reason why
you were on dancing with the stars
where we met
was because of mark cuban
no oh no no
um deena katz okay and her husband was
in the technology and suggested me and
she was one of the producers i remember
dina county she brought me on and to
this day when she asked me to go on
certain shows or events i do it because
it's her i like her very much yeah and
she was the one now mark cuban during
dancing with the stars i had so many
injuries from moving my body in ways
you've never moved it before i had a
broken toe i couldn't feel for weeks and
then finally got it they did an x-ray it
was broken but everything hurt every
single toe all the way up to your hips
aren't that much
trying this for so long and uh mark
human at one point um the the paparazzi
got on to i was wearing a cast on my
foot for a while
and he got onto and he phoned and said
he had a doctor who would help me out
with advice i don't know what to do what
not to do yeah i love him that was
really nice i've met him a couple times
yeah i think he's great he is great man
i wish he were president but
yeah
um and and i think that
one of the greatest moments of dancing
with this star's history is
you doing the worm
don't ask me we were in rehearsal and
somebody said oh you could do the worm
what's the worm
so one of one of the technical guys
filmers he tried to emulate it okay and
then i didn't practice it at all i did
not no idea how to do it maybe i
practice it one one or two times you
know like for ten years it was it was
and i said will i do it on the show
it couldn't have been better it could
not have been more a more entertaining
moment thank god i'm so proud to be
known for that i don't care if they gave
us a 10 total score
you know but um oh no that was uh yeah
memorable moments i'd love to be a part
of them and then you guys struck up a
friendship on dancing with stars like
very much did how did that kind of grow
and start i don't remember steve might
have come to talk to me and just say
anybody who talks to me as a friend i'm
really shy i don't meet many friends but
no i um i don't know if you ever got i
went out for every one of the
the
celebrities and professional dancers and
i made little bags of gifts little gift
bags and i i'll tell you when you're
rehearsing you don't have any spare time
drove around to to bookstore after
bookstore after bookstore always look
for books that had little like factoid
type books different different ones not
every bag was i remember and then i then
i put in a sheet of two dollar bills
strange to have them on sheets put in
for everybody and i put in my metal
business cards i have these with me
and uh put them in there and then i i
typed a letter on a computer about what
a great experiences was and i put it in
every bag for 27 others but then for
each of the 27 yourself included i hand
wrote in cursive a note as to why they
were good people wow every single one of
them and the next season i told donny
osmond about he said he was going to do
it but he never had the time yeah i mean
that's why that was uh that was but i
was figured i'm going to get kicked off
real soon and i better get this done
because everybody gives gifts and i'm
going to be out of the loop and that's
why that's why i was rushing to do it
wow i think that's a dying art now
dancing with the stars yeah you were one
of the greatest discoveries in dancing
with the stars you know of course all
the people and how the show was made but
uh man we were we had to go i ride my
segway to the show oh yeah and i and i
passed by this wood ranch barbecue they
won't have them up in northern
california that is still my favorite
place janet and i will drive down south
just to go to a wood ranch um just i'm
addicted to
their i don't know their barbecue sauce
wow
nice yeah and then that was i associate
that with dancing with the stars i don't
remember too much of the actual dancing
right yeah
the wood ranch that's what we got yeah i
mean it's a story i've told so many
times but i'll never forget how
i i got i too got injured my back was
was hurt on dancing with the stars and i
told you on the set that i was thinking
about getting a macbook air so that my
backpack would be lighter because it was
hurting my back and when you heard that
right away you said oh cool i'll go with
you to the apple store
yeah and you can use my 10 employee
discount yeah and i just thought that
was so fantastically hilarious i said
there is no way i'm going to turn down
an opportunity to go to the apple store
with waz and uses 10 discounts i helped
a couple other dancers that wanted to
get new phones or something but i really
saved the life of jonathan roberts or
somebody um he was one of the
professional dancers his phone went bad
that day and he ran down to the um
uh sherman oaks uh mall and he knocked
on the apple door we don't open for an
hour we don't open till 11. he says i've
got to get to the show uh see wozniak is
on they opened the door and got him wow
yeah that's glad for that
and and uh and he got you the discount
when you went to he did yeah and it was
the craziest experience because this
apple employee
steve called it called him over and he
said hey my my friend here is going to
buy this computer and use my discount
and this guy somehow didn't recognize
steve oh that said
you know what 40 years ago i was 30.
he looked at him and he said but are you
an apple employee and steve cheerfully
said
yeah i have an apple employee number
it's one
i didn't say it that way but he said
what's your what's your employee number
and i said one you get a little shocked
no what's your number one
yeah i go through that a lot of times
for service uh and it remains number one
on your card i still have an active card
it's an app i'm an employee i get a
little i'm the only person that's had a
salary every day since we started the
company
and speaking of the 10 discount any
employee of apple for any friend
relative whatever could always get a 10
discount on product back then
and i'll tell you a story that's not
really known i got a call one day in
later days and it was from steve jobs
job's sister the one that i knew that he
grew up with you know nuts
and
she worked at a local community college
and her computer was going bad it'd been
too many years and she had asked steve
her brother for a 10 discount and he
wouldn't give just a discount he
wouldn't give it to her
and so i bought her computer of course
but
that was just um shocking wow yeah some
things that how does a person ever do
these things and some people can do
anything
i i heard something that was really
shocking i was watching pawn stars and
somebody brought in a computer
the pawn stars to pawn and it was the
like uh the version two or the original
one from the 80s and they're telling the
story and they said that you would go
around to in palo alto and fix people's
you'd do house calls and fix people's
actual computers
and i just thought that was
i mean
in earlier days much earlier days oh my
gosh anybody called me had a problem i
would go down help them out but that was
when you could actually fix them you
actually knew every bit of code in there
you knew what was wrong how to find it
nowadays it's just too much of a mess
for
a human to do very much you know how
would you even find if your computer has
malware
millions of bytes of code you can't find
it
you know even an expert can't really
find and determine necessarily that
you've got something's hurting you so
that's how it is today is that just
because of that's how technology has
progressed or is that sort of by design
that it's not progressed because we
could always i don't know it moore's law
we were you know when we started apple
you only put about 2 000 transistors
neurons on a chip and now you can put 60
billion on one chip for 25 cents
manufacturing cost maybe made with
inflation's up to 50 cents yeah but um
yeah it's gotten way too complicated i
long all the time janet would tell you
all the time for the the old school the
old school ways and the old days
uh you know when you actually own stuff
too
but now now you can just rent it
especially look at a car like a like a
like a tesla they'll just totally take
your world that you know and totally
change it you can't find things and you
can't operate them and if one little
button you need to be able to get to
something with your voice isn't working
you can't get to that feature at all
until they take over it's been two
months or something trying to get a
button replaced one button on the
steering wheel
this is on
the worst service of our lives man we
would never buy another tesla wow but we
have an electric car in order but it's
it's a newer one
520 miles range tesla canceled their
caller car that was going to be like
that and um 20 and it charges at 350
kilowatt speed tests our tesla only
charges at 140 max
so it'll be much quicker charging on the
road you can drive all the way to la in
that car and no charge at all and
usually your hotel has something to
change what company is that the uh
lucid lucid lucid new company they have
a showroom that we went to we passed by
the street and janet saw it on the side
so we turned around and went in there
and in the showroom in beverly hills and
we were also buy one that we saw from
the outside in um
scottsdale fashion mall
so they're they they're opening up their
showrooms but it's gonna it's costly to
bring a new car like that to the market
it's yeah
it's still a bit of an expensive car and
they haven't made very many lucids yet
he said
uh if you want to do something with
voice command and that is just it makes
me so interested they turned off the
user interface menu to do some things
and the only way you can do it with is
with voice but if the voice button's
broken i've had a break on me once
before and
intake didn't take two months to get
fixed but
what made me curious is to ask would you
ever use
uh alexa or siri or you know like for
fearless lectures built into our new
lucid
and we can use our it has carplay apple
carplay and android auto so you can use
your phone as your navigation and other
things so so you're not concerned about
them listening in and
you know all of this uh well actually
yeah sort of concerned but i also
like alexa in my home
and we have for example i'll pull out my
phone sometimes when we're driving home
and i'll i'll call x and i'll tap in and
i'll drop into the the alexa in our
kitchen i'll start talking to the dogs
and they you hear me
mommy and daddy are coming i i just
remember there was it's at some point i
think i might have bought bought some
product and and then i was setting it up
and and it asked me i was prompted we
want to use alexa and it said like
it it's gonna record
when i see yeah kind of warnings you
know yeah and the iphone is really good
about telling you nowadays if something
might get you into being observed watch
shared
and get known i go know as much as i can
on that and i use
oh i for what they call it that hides
your ip address
oh yeah yeah vpn no
vpn's one thing i even built my own on a
raspberry pi built my own um open vpn
the best vpn there is in my home on a
real ip address that i have real ipv54
so when i'm overseas i can even use my
own vpn instead of others that are known
their their server addresses are known
and you know the countries you're in
that don't like you doing everything can
spot those addresses and block them
you know vpn but vpn's one way but no
apple i forget what they call it oh my
gosh it's it's a little catchy two-word
phrase kind of but it means you're going
you're going with your ip address hidden
from everything okay yeah apple's gotten
a lot better with privacy
and that's the stanford yeah they stand
for it maybe it's just by accident that
wound up where they were with what they
had but i'm so glad for that i want to
be uh
you know what we share photos in our
families on on on icloud cost two
dollars a month right you share photos
with albums and other friends of the
family and can be in on it
and and
it's protected it's private nobody can
take the data you know and find out
everything you're doing so it's
but but uh facebook says oh apple is so
expensive they can do that
two dollars a month why don't you do it
no just let us pay for privacy on on
facebook that's my biggest
of all big tech facebook's number one
that i don't like i mean you got to be
in the social web but i don't so i i
pretty much avoid all the social web
i mean i had facebook i had facebook for
a lot of years never used it and i wound
up saying yes to everybody want to be a
friend so i had 5 000 facebook friends
all people i don't know
and then then for three months i
actually went and started looking at
facebook because i kind of like little
videos of dogs being dogs and big dogs
being saved by people no this is true i
spent an hour every night on tick tock
just waiting for that nice to see that
and um and and then i found that
whenever i was at an airport i was
flying a lot back then like 200 flights
a year i'd just be find myself scrolling
through and i said if i have solitaire i
don't need this because it became so
habit for me and after three months yeah
and i don't like habits because that's
addiction
yeah that's addiction and i want to be i
think for myself and choose what i'm
going to do so i i totally we dropped
facebook janet and i just dropped our
accounts
deactivated them didn't quite drop them
so i'm still scared a bit too had to
take facebook off my devices because i
read how it can still grab data and
facebook even when you're not using it
right i i don't believe this is right
because you should have it honest that
every person who uses it knows what
they're doing like steve would post
something and i would click like you
know i'm laughing i'd click like it's
from me to steve
wait a minute
no it's not to steve he doesn't ever see
it it's from me to 100 advertisers
yeah learning things about me learning
things about me and
that is just shocking because that's not
how we think of it we think like is a
way that i can actually
indicate what i like and not that it's
being used to advertise to me and uh if
you're a creative person
as some of us are you don't want people
to know what you're going to say next
what you're going to do next where
you're going to shop what you're going
to buy when we should when we should
give you this alert and all the time i
notice that uh sometimes devices that
sort of guess on me guess you know
you'll want to do this now
no today i've got something else going
on you know or traffic is not this way
today because it's it's a midweek
holiday
and and those algorithms just don't know
what a dumbest human knows and driving a
tesla will teach you that we drive we've
driven the tesla for a long time lots of
long road trips we've taken at least
eight three thousand mile round trips to
kansas and back and many to um
yellowstone and back and we've gone up
to canada we just love driving all the
time during during 2020 co-vid
restrictions stay at home we just got in
our car it's an extension of our home
and we drove to every corner california
and back the same day you know way up 10
hours up to eureka
and 10 hours back wow the mendocino
forest oh redwood forest never ever
forget it and we went to all the
national parks in california and saw the
biggest trees in the world and all that
you know so that was that was really a
great little escape but um the tesla
when it's navigating it just makes if
you ever put on turn on its features
well anything actually just cruise
control
the number of times we've been on an
interstate we drive 10 40 70 and 80 all
the time and then we're on interstate
and all of a sudden we're going 75 miles
an hour and all of a sudden the car
screeches the brakes the dogs get thrown
forward and it slows down if there's
nobody in the rearview mirror that we
have to speed up for i let it go all the
way down go down 25 miles an hour on an
interstate a tesla with nothing around
no cars around no nothing sometimes
there is a car around you say that must
have been it but sometimes with nothing
around this is so dangerous it's
happened to us 100 times at least
because we drive so much and then if you
turn on the steering where it's steering
my gosh sometimes it kind of goes over
the line a little and there's a truck
right there or if a truck kind of moves
towards you a little you should a human
driver would just pull away a few inches
and it doesn't do that remember
recently just recently once it i'm
driving along
and all of a sudden there's a semi on my
right the car lurched towards the semi
and i had to quickly grab control wow i
mean that would have been death this is
just
horrible horrible assuming that these
algorithms can do what a dumbest human
could do okay you're on a freeway and
there's a big there's and there's
there's a merger lane coming in well
tesla starts driving it the lane gets
wider where it is on the lines and it
starts driving like a drunk person but
the car coming up ahead as a smart human
you would just see we're gonna call
we're gonna be equal so i'll back off a
little
just easy to do tesla gets let you go
right up next to it and it screeches the
brake line to get out of the way you
know because it has to by then this is
just not the way human beings ever think
and they used to make it sound like oh
artificial intelligence will be like a
human we have eyes the tesla has has
cameras and it'll be able to do what a
human does
and trouble is we don't know how the
brain's wired we do not know how the
brain does that stuff um i know because
i was a psychology major and we don't
even know that our memories are in the
brain
memory of this medium here don't know
that's in the brain i i took all the
strongest subjects in memory and
psychology and read every book i could
and went walking on the streets of
berkeley and buying more books from the
older days
and where's memory the best they had was
it must be everywhere because you take
any part of the brain out and no memory
gets lost from the rat so it must be
everywhere wow
but now i came up with something 40
years ago i have to go back well 1981
whatever that was 40 years
um i i came up with a statement to to
make fun of the fact that the books
don't know anything i said the strongest
correlation you can come up with is that
between the ages of 6 and 10 as we had
learned you lose two things your
childhood autobiographic memories things
that you've done as a child and you lose
your teeth
right and that's the strongest best
correlation now it's 2022 or something
one of these years 2021 i don't know
what it is i don't do years but you can
look up you you can search for teeth
memory you're gonna be shocked what you
find today so you mentioned alzheimer's
tests in the saliva and the gums you're
saying maybe your childhood memories are
in your
teeth i was saying there's no way
memories are stored in teeth okay
that's what i'm saying but if i say
never but i have a stronger more logical
mathematical explanation of where
memories could be then you'll find in
any book i would make i was just trying
to point out how weak the books were
nobody listened to me of course i wrote
it up for the professor but
do you oh sorry steve i was just like it
reminds me of uh the
thing that i came up with with which is
that uh my theory
that
the brain does not generate
consciousness the brain is not a
transmitter of consciousness but rather
it's a receiver and and so i have this
uh this metaphor
and this analogy to to describe what i'm
saying is that
um
we're like a radio kind of yeah a lot of
people want to hear that and you know
all the knowledge of the world is in
waves but you know what i just i just
disown anything that says we can have
between people and you know some psychic
connection through the air i always
disown it all right telepathy
yeah you don't think telepathy is
possible
correct like the men who stare at goats
is all [ __ ] probably i don't know
that one but i just i just think that uh
you know like like
you could take your your body like uh to
kill the body
but but you're not killing the
consciousness you know like i don't buy
that okay but then i accept you you have
good you have a good thinking if you
start with that as your assumption yes
you can come up with yes there's
something out there i can't disprove it
right so you're just as good as you're
thinking just as good as mine mine just
always wanted you know mathematical
scientific proofs you can hook a circuit
together and see a like i love that too
i love that too and you said that you
you love dog videos and
i got a message any animal really yeah
of me too i got a message from you when
i posted a dog video
after i found wendy in the streets of
peru
i got a message from you that you loved
the video
that uh that i posted about finding
wendy
absolutely yeah i remember i was in a
country once and this dog at the airport
came up and i i treated it nicely i
don't think i had any food anyone to
follow me to the car and i felt it
wanted me and
so when i left that for a few days later
from that trip i just wanted to go to
the airport and find that dog again and
somebody somebody in that country had
said that they would harbor it harbor
the dog and keep it for me quarantine it
and get it shipped to me
but never ran into that dog again i just
fall in love with dogs so easily yeah
yeah tell me about it you were talking
earlier about uh steve jobs sister and
you knew her from growing up so you and
steve were like friends as
you kind of disowned that whole family
is it getting a little bit hot in here
or is this story about to be totally
intense
now in other intense news i got to tell
you we've been doing crazy numbers with
our merchandise operation and if you
aren't in the e-commerce game i dare say
you are blowing it now what's the secret
to our success with my merchandising
it's called ship station all right what
is ship station it's one easy to use
interface which integrates every
different selling platform amazon etsy
your website you name it any way you're
selling it you can sell it with
shipstation and they're gonna give you
the best rates on all of the carriers
like ups
post office the dhl come on i mean it's
shipping time baby and if you want to
get a free 60-day trial of no hassle
easy to use shipping
just go to
shipstation.com in the top right hand
corner there's a microphone just like
this one you're gonna click that and
then boom type in the promo code stevo
and get off to the race is figuring out
how easy
shipping can be and i'm not kidding
about shipping a lot of stuff like this
insane boom box with the microphone it's
a traveling pa system baby and we're
shipping them with ship stations so one
more time go to shipstation.com
click the microphone in the top right
hand corner use the promo code stevo and
you are off to the races with 60 days of
totally free hassle-free
use of ship station
it's time to come up in the world now
let's get into this story
as far as i could tell i mean they were
nice family as far as i could tell just
like any other family i didn't even know
he was adopted
oh so he was adopted but you guys grew
up together i never knew he all the way
up to starting apple and way late in
apple when there were some reports about
it he found his father that's when i
learned oh wow
his his natural father
he wanted to prove he came from real
brilliant brains or something
you know
but you know
i don't know brain smartness school
smartness i don't buy into that a lot
like most people do dna smartness i
think i think
your experiences in life accidents you
stumble into it every bit of walking
around on the street is education sure
everything you're doing your life's
education you're learning to have good
thoughts and think about it if you are
allowed to be creative
that's i really dislike the fact that uh
doing things outside of the main ways
you're supposed to do things that's why
i talked about rules i just hate that
because you go to school and a kid might
want to know what's in a drawer no you
can't there's 30 kids in the class you
start learning learning that oh your
parents your teachers won't let you
go off and wander in your own little
directions the best times of my life
when i was young was doing you know
pranks and playing around with my my
friends and riding bikes and all that
stuff
and you know stuff without school and
you know without parents it was the best
times and i ran into a lot of the people
that started these big tech companies or
important people in apple and they
always went back to all the pranks they
played and the fun that they had as kids
and i when you die i remember reading
once i was in the hall closet
one was about 20 years old i was doing
the hallway in my house and i was
reading some article i don't read any
business articles especially that back
then
and it was about this guy sumner
redstone who ran viacom and he was
selling a 50 million dollar company but
he had to catch an airplane real quick
to some of the city to buy another one
and he's doing all these huge amounts of
money and that was a lot back then it's
like 500 000 now
and uh i thought would i want to be that
guy when i die and i don't know i just
done some prank with some friends and or
would i rather be the one that's
laughing over what we the fun we had in
life and i decided right then and there
life's about happiness not
accomplishment how happy you are do the
fun things in life and live a fun life
and i have forever just like
you and many like you for sure
so so that's the formula for happiness
well that's where i came up with it i
said what is happiness
what is happiness and i felt it from
thinking about you know something we've
done and laughing
laughing that's a feeling so it's the
emotions of happiness and so the good
thing is smiles smiles is positive i
said happiness equals smiles minus
frowns
frowns are when you get upset at things
and i found out that you walk around if
you get really entangled in believing
something should be a certain way this
is my way and not other other um
you're unhappy so i said don't ever
argue
you can have differences opinion and be
different in your thinking but you both
have good minds that came to the
conclusion from you from a perspective
so you both have good minds and not and
my father told me always be liked is the
secret to going up in life and and i
always wanted to be liked so i didn't
want to argue with people i never did
and but also other things that go wrong
don't focus on the past what went wrong
you know at first you're mad but then
forget it what do we do now to fix it
what's the next step that's positive
constructive you know car gets done it
don't try to blame somebody for debt in
your car go get it fixed
right was it hard not to argue when
they're when you're starting a company
there's creative differences i mean how
did you learn because that must have
been you had never in my life never i
was extremely shy i really wouldn't talk
to people i didn't want to talk to
people i didn't want to have
confrontation
which is arguments and um no and we
might have differences of opinion but i
would never ever take a strong you're
wrong never you're wrong
almost never almost never i mean there's
some extreme cases maybe yeah i heard
something like you threatened to walk
from apple
something about the production of the
apple
two or three or four yeah they wanted to
tell the story phony story
came about yes we had a shareholders
meeting the apple ii my apple ii was all
mine was all of the income of apple for
the first 10 years of the company
what gave apple the springboard to
become what it is now okay it was that
product was important it was bringing in
millions of dollars a month all the
revenues of the company we had we had
just introduced the macintosh we had a
shareholders meeting all you heard
macintosh mcintosh mackinac management
they didn't mention the apple ii once
okay and so after the shareholders
meeting i went back to the apple 2 3
building nice triangle building on 280
and uh the
the apple the great people that ran that
division and the engineers on the apple
ii side were just storming they were
just so mad they were talking about
ready to quit
because they've been so insulted by like
being treated like they were nothing
that's how jobs treated it the macintosh
is everything and apple ii they're bozos
and
and they were threatening to quit well
they don't have a voice that i have
so i called up john scully i kind of
blamed him i don't know what's coming
from jobs call up john scully and i just
read him you know the book from my
perspective these are good people and
they're being forgotten and and that's
just wrong john john said well we
mentioned apple two twice i don't know
where it was it must have been some
little double digits
yeah and i hung up on him he was our ceo
i hung up on him but i just did it so
he'd know how we were feeling
the others in in my division and after
and then the wall street journal called
and they got wind of this this um
disagreement or whatever and i said no
i'm leaving to start a new startup
company to build the first universal
remote control for tvs vcrs
laserdisc which nobody in america had
hardly um there was only one hi-fi that
had a remote control and i had it a bang
olufsen and i had a satellite dish that
built myself big huge there was no
satellite subscriptions yet and so i had
five controls how do you introduce them
to one so i started a company and i went
on blackboard and showed the apple
engineers in my division what i was
planning to do so they'd know that i
wasn't undercutting apple or doing
something apple would want to do brought
me the nicest lever kept me on the
payroll even kept me as an employee but
the wall street journal called and they
said you know i told them what i was
upset about at the shareholders meeting
and they they wrote that that was why i
was leaving
and i said no it's not why i'm leaving
i'm leaving to do this new project a new
startup
and they wrote it the other way and
steve jobs really believed that i was
you know against the company and and but
he didn't have enough the wherewithal to
see that i was still an employee
and it was really funny because after we
were building that remote control we had
the plastic pieces
and well we went to frog design to make
the plastics frog design was apple's big
design
people that steve jobs liked the lot and
i said you do projects for other
companies yeah
so we had them designed some possible
remote control shapes
and then i heard the head of frog design
talking to my partner joannis on the
phone
and the head of frog design told how
steve jobs came by on his bicycle one
day and and the head of frog design
hermit eslinger or whatever his name was
showed him showed him the remote control
said look what we're doing for your
partner steve wozniak
and jobs threw it against the wall he
said put it in a box and ship it to me i
own everything you do
or apple owns everything you do
i listened and heard those words what
human being what decent human being
could ever ever do something that way
you know i would never bring up a kid to
be that way or encourage anyone else to
to be that kind of a person
wow
that was that was that's you know you
know you run into um i don't know
narcissism i'm in control of everything
was he always that way like because you
knew him when you guys when did you guys
first meet first of all the world knows
about two steve jobs
steve jobs one was ruthless a lot of
people did a lot of nasty things but he
was good to some people that were
important to him good engineers and
whatever he was actually good and never
did something like that directly to me
except a couple incidents i just
described one
and then he went away and he came back
steve drops too and he was a little more
refined
and i don't even know if that's true
because there were still some things
going on that were
very jobs just somebody walks in an
elevator and just what they're wearing
you're fired
that still that would still happen so
but i knew steve jobs zero
for five years before apple we were
friends he'd come into town every so
often see my latest invention and turn
it into money for both of us
um so that was uh we had a good
relationship we played pranks we played
in the world we played pranks on each
other um we joked around with um the day
i met him he was 16 years old and had no
albums
okay so i brought in my house i had
every bob dylan album and i let him read
the liner notes and the interviews with
bob dylan and then the lyrics to the
songs desolation row and songs like that
this became so important to us that his
words had like life meaning and so we've
we followed up people that had dylan
memorabilia we would drive long
distances to meet with them and and then
we would go to concerts and everything
dillon concerts that was a big part of
our life
so but this is before apple
who you are
in life
gets formed it's called personality
your personality isn't going to change
ever
neither is mine nate is yours
when your your personality settles down
between 18 and 23 years old college
years and that's who you are going to be
forever now steve jobs had always wanted
a path to be somebody important in the
world but he didn't have any academic
background he's living on communities
like with abs you know nothing finally
had me was about it
and uh and so he and he wanted the path
to be someone and now all of a sudden
with my apple ii
big money was willing to be put into it
and steve jobs is now founder of a
company he didn't have a title really
just founder of a company that had big
money this was how he was going to
spring into the world you had to have a
company you had to make a lot of money
you had to become one of those important
people
and he started just talking like all
computer intelligence came from him
i just wanted to be an engineering away
from other people i didn't want to be
near press i just wanted to work on more
designs i kept design after design after
design of the design i did
andy wanted to share
all of the schematics and how everything
not from apple this company when the
money got put in we had to incorporate
and i was forced to leave
hewlett-packard where i had determined i
would be an engineer for life engineers
are good politicians aren't management
is politicians striving for different
job positions and and having to say bad
things about people and i couldn't do
that but i could do engineering so um um
what were you saying well i just did
because i i i learned this that
you had the the apple ii was expandable
with the eight slots oh okay coming on
yes coming on for designing the products
um
they were all mine the apple one apple
ii nobody helped i did all the hardware
all the software when i look back to how
much software i did i look back now my
old designs and i say how could i ever
have had the energy to do that and how
could i have come up with things that
were so far out of the books so far out
of the books color
our first logo was six colors you might
wonder why
and it's because the apple ii computer i
design games for atari like breakout a
game would be a hundred chips and a
thousand wires
and an engineer like me would have to
keep track of every wire it might take
six months to make a new game prototype
the apple ii computer was the first time
ever that arcade games it was um arcade
games were being started by atari right
here in los gatos california where we
are today
um and i could go down there and learn
to play games earlier and steve jobs
would be wiring up my design for
breakout we delivered a working breakout
but
the apple ii computer was the first time
ever that arcade games were color
and the first time ever they were
software a nine-year-old kid could write
a good game for the day in one day one
day in basic
this was a change for gaming as much as
for computers that was a machine and
where it all came from was i was on the
atari floor and i thought man it'll be
neat if someday these games are in color
it would be beautiful
and then my head went back i was an
analog engineer i was a television
engineer too i went back to how color is
a sine wave on a wire that goes at a
certain the exact right speed and it
shows up as red
if it's a little later in time it's blue
you know and that sort of thing and all
of a sudden i know there's there's books
and books on mathematics differential
calculus to design these circuits how
all these you know existential waves and
mathematics created color tv their books
on it
and i just said what if you took a
little number out of a computer that's
ones and zeros
right out of the computer memory and you
put it on a wire into the tv if the ones
and zeros got fed at the right rate i
knew every color tv would think it was
color
never could any book have talked about
that little simple simple approach just
a pixel in a certain spot shows up as
green and a pixel the next spot over
shows up as red i mean um that was i
mean that was that was kind of amazing
but i just thought that way i don't know
where these ideas came from one after
another after another for about 10 years
in my life
and even before apple
um right and you're starting with the
blue box you're just laying in bed
thinking about this like oh my god i
have to put this in the oh no i didn't
sleep for four days and nights doing
breakout for atari this was not possible
even for me to do in four days a day
so your head but if you're not sleepy if
you're if you're not getting to sleep
your head drifts off in weird tangents
you know in between standing up you
might sleep a little bit whatever it's
called and that's where this this color
idea had popped in just i'm start
thinking about it in my head and seeing
the solution that wound up being uh you
know a huge part of apple and when you
come up with these ideas you want to
share publicly with everybody like what
the idea is and how to replicate it not
exactly i was in a club of people
stanford professors on down all sorts of
people that weren't rich and wealthy but
they're talking about if we ever had our
own computers it's getting close to the
price with a microprocessor we could
afford our own computers and they were
trying to build kits that weren't even
useful computers they were something i
built five years before the matter of
fact right when i met steve jobs i was
building a computer my own design
and they were trying to do it the wrong
way and i wanted things that were human
keyboard a typewriter's human a keyboard
and a display and i already learned that
my tv could be a display for pong you
know in games like that breakout but i'd
also then gone and made my tv a terminal
i made it so it could actually show
letter words and connect over the over
the phone line to a thing a new thing
called the arpanet
what is the arpanet
today it's the internet yeah they were
on that time there were only six
computers on the arpanet started by the
us government to put far away computers
and i could dial a number in palo alto
and then i could log onto the artbanet
and then i could see a list of six
computers and i could pick one at mit
and go there and then it would say do
you want to log in as a guest or as a as
a user guest i didn't have accounts
and then i'd get on i could read files
and i could play games like chess and
this was a terminal i'd built
and that was one step closer to the
computer now in the club i finally found
out what a microprocessor was i hadn't
looked at them since the early ones
which are too weak for me i like
computers
and this microprocessor i took home a
data sheet oh my gosh the microprocessor
is like all of the computers i designed
in high school one after another after
another another another that's how i got
so skilled and good at making them with
few parts and i said oh my gosh i know
how to i'm gonna have my own computer
now
problem is i couldn't afford 400 for an
intel microprocessor
and then i found i could get one from
hewlett packard where i worked for 40
a motorola one so i designed my whole
thing on the drafting table for the
motorola processor
and basically i was taking that terminal
it could talk to a far away computer and
it could type back to my tv from mit
i just put my own computer the brains as
the microprocessor and the memory had to
be dynamic memory
everybody else was copying intel data
sheets on a data sheet with with lines
on paper you can only show
microprocessor has address one going to
address one on a chip address two going
to address two you're going to show
straight wires that's static ram cost
four times as much it was going to make
getting a useful computer a 4k computer
that could run a programming language
out of the range of normal humans no i
put in the dynamic rams one-fourth as
many chips i always count things by
chips and yes what's what is a dynamic
ram compared to a static ram
it forgets everything it knows every bit
in the chip gets forgotten in two
thousandth of a second
so you have to get in and supply some
extra signals to make sure it
triggers basically every row or every
column in the chip to make sure it it
reads and rewrites its own data every
two thousandth of a second and that
takes some chips
but one of the things it takes is a
counter that goes this row and then that
row and that row and that row counter i
already had counters for horizontal and
vertical on the tv i just reused them a
second time i always did everything i
could to be clever tricks today you'd
call it hacking but um you know i
anyway so anyway i had the right device
and i took it down this was called um it
didn't have a name there's no company
steve jobs was out of town he didn't
know it existed so i took it to the
homebrew computer club
and i passed out schematics to everyone
in the club here's how you can build it
here are the chips you use here's the
code that i wrote for it and um
everyone in the club i passed it out but
everybody looking over my shoulders had
seen computers of the past with all
these switches and lights
and the computer of the future was the
the this became the apple one eventually
and from that point on no computer was
built without a keyboard and a video
display that was a turning point in
history but i didn't didn't own it i'd
given it away public domain because i
wanted to start the revolution these are
the people that are going to start the
revolution give him the give him the
tools to do it and then steve came into
town it's the opposite of what a movie
shows
yeah dude the waz is about to set the
record straight about how history really
happened and i'm gonna set the record
straight about what's going to happen in
my bedroom tonight with lux it's going
to start out with me chewing up some
delicious blue chew tablets two of them
to be precise
and it's going to end up about a half an
hour later with me hard as a rock
bringing lux to bone town does that
sound like a good time you bet it does
you know why because it is a good time
and if you haven't tried this man i'm
just saying
you might want to because it is a lot of
fun and
what is the bluetooth tablet if you
don't know it's a delicious chewable
tablet with the same active ingredient
as viagra and cialis except it costs
just a fraction of the price and for the
listeners of the wild ride podcast i can
get you a entire month's supply
absolutely for free
if you go to
bluechew.com and use the promo code
stevo but wait do you need a
prescription for these tablets you do
but you don't have to go to an awkward
in-person visit to the doctor nope you
just go to bluechew.com and consult with
one of their online medical providers
couldn't be more quick and easy use the
promo code stevo and boom your tablets
are on the way an entire month's supply
absolutely for free all you have to pay
is five bucks for shipping i'm telling
you it's gonna make you
harder than a computer geek listening to
the rest of this podcast yeah dude
bluetooth baby get on it have fun and
now let's get back to it
there's a movie with ashton kutcher
steve comes and finds me in a basement a
big geek and he calls me to a club to
show it off to real people
what a farce he'd never been to the club
i'd been there every day since it
started i was a hero at the club i was
like here at the club passing my stuff
around showing it off and uh took him
down to see the interest in it you know
my tv and
my board and keyboards and wiring and
lots of stuff osha would not have liked
transformers with bare wires exposed but
took it down he saw the interest in
that's when he said we should start a
company
and what he proposed was not a computer
company
it was a company to make something he
had understood from something he'd done
before in his life make a pc board for
twenty dollars then people can get chips
from their employers plug the chips in
and it's all soldered it's all done they
don't have to hook wire to wire to wire
to wire that big mess instead of two
weeks they build it in one day
and we'll build the pc boards for twenty
dollars we'll sell them for 40.
when you have no money no bank accounts
no rich relatives that's how you have to
think yeah what can we do today with
what we have and that was our start
and um and it sprung and it went further
and further now hewlett-packard i
offered it to them first the personal
computer i loved my company and i wanted
them to build it but they turned me down
five times
five times for the personal computer
they were just like we just don't see a
future there wouldn't have been a future
if they'd done it crazy the reason is is
they wouldn't have built a fun machine
that could play games they would have
built back then hewlett-packard only
built machines that engineers used you
know with dials and switches and power
supplies and cables
only for engineers they would have built
a boring dumb computer that engineers
could have a little tiny black and white
screen chiclets and they eventually
started a program on my floor in the lab
to do that and i just built a device
with microprocessor that they were using
with dynamic rams they were going to use
they had five guys assigned to writing
the basic language i'd written one all
myself on mine
and they wouldn't let me on the project
even
so they turned down the personal
computer and you
built the first personal computer the
first really well the first really good
the apple one
was not
you know very quickly was not going to
be the substance of our of our life but
we got a 50 000 order
for pc boards with chips on them we
didn't have 50 000
we had to borrow 5 000 from a friend and
we got the parts on 30 days credit built
the computers up delivered them and got
paid cash in 10 days we had 30 days to
pay for the parts and that's what you do
when you have no money you just i mean
steve jobs was a brilliant brilliant at
finding the ways that we could do
something and make a step and this but
that was before that was apple one
before we ever shipped the apple one
we were secretly showing my apple ii to
people that back in atlantic city they
had a show called pc76 and we didn't
want any of these other little startup
companies to see what we had so we went
down late at night when they were all
gone and there was just one guy there
with a projector i wanted to see if it
works on a projection tv was that new is
this is my color gonna my color output
gonna work on a projection tv and we
hooked it up with that guy and we did
and that guy was seeing all the things
that young people were trying to bring
to the world as computers and he said
this is the one i want
you know we always do
that too so we were and we were just
showing off the apple one we hadn't
shipped one yet so we knew the apple ii
was our our future for a big company wow
that was the one the app because the
apple one wasn't designed as a wozniak
computer it was a wasatch terminal for
the arpanet modified into a computer a
little but not really designed as a
computer at this point when you're
getting a fifty thousand dollar purchase
order are you guys are you guys apple
inc or i'm working for hewlett-packard
my salary is 25 000. i got so scared i
had hewlett packard sent a description
of the personal computer to every one of
their divisions and they all turned it
down but i mean are you are you when
somebody's writing a check to you and
steve are they writing it to apple inc
or that's not even a company yet they're
just writing it to you guys that live in
palo alto um we weren't inc
this was a partnership for that apple
one phase yeah and uh and people just
loaned us money i think just
to steve wozniak or something yeah good
friend from high school um i i we did
have a name apple
apple computer as a partnership
performed as a three-person partnership
a partnership partner who had 10 percent
sold out after a few weeks
is it right that it's
a mystery to everybody
why it's called apple
well steve jobs one time i picked him up
the airport were driving down 101 or
something and he said i got a great name
for the company apple computer my first
response was what about apple records
well they're a record company we're a
computer company i said that's all it
takes he said yeah
and uh it's funny because we lost
hundreds of millions of dollars to the
kingdom oh you got to see the beatles
and then we got lost more huge money to
the lawyers that we sued for losing the
case um but um
no but it was just such a great name who
could ever turn that down those were the
days you didn't need to have a technical
name that said what your company does
you could be anybody it was a fun fun
loving time and on the last day of
dancing with the stars the finale when
we all came back
long before before it was going to go on
the air i was sitting up almost nobody
was there and i'm sitting up on the
balcony right next to a doctor who had
treated my horrible wound which he
didn't talk about my hamstring wound
that cost me a week of practice
and i sit next to him he said that his
brother worked on that farm was up in
oregon with steve and it was his brother
that went up to steve and said i got a
great name for your company wow that's
the real far-off truth yeah i don't know
if that's ever told
and but you believe that story that's oh
totally wow oh totally somebody no
reason to make anything up and there
weren't that many people on that farm oh
yeah um
scott said something that
would never have occurred to me but he
thought that the apple logo with the
bite taken out of it
represented uh
eve biting the apple of the tree of
knowledge
after you have something you like you
kind of say well what what are some
things that we could say about it right
so i'm sure it's been said but what
happened was mike markle put in the big
money to build a thousand computers for
the apple ii yeah he put up the money he
was a third equal partner we had three
equal partners and he was the adult in
the house he told us how you form a
company who you hire what their
responsibilities are he was the
marketing guy at the time he was he was
into marketing pushing marketing steve
jobs could never consider doing any
engineering he didn't really know
engineering he couldn't design things he
never knew what computer hardware
software was really i could get into
more stories about that but so steve
followed in the wanted to go in the
marketing direction and the business and
the speaking and learning how everybody
operates in a company but he didn't
really have there wasn't a title that he
could have yet before we started the
company so mike markle put up the
um
that that money and we were able to
build a thousand ample twos we had some
obstacles on the way like
steve had found a place that squeezes
motorcycle seats you put some foam in
you squeeze it under pressure and it
forms a nice motorcycle seat and that
they could make a plastic case for the
uh for the apple ii computer
and
uh
we could get a few a week and they were
just so loud it wasn't like normal
plastic quality we were we barely we had
to survive for something like six months
before we got real abs plastic from hong
kong
so somebody puts an order for a thousand
apple twos
you're putting them together one by one
or at this time do you have a team
well
at that point in time it was so early
that our pc boards were still being made
by a local company and then they stuff
the parts in and they wave solder it we
don't plug the parts in then we drive
down and pick them up same thing with
the apple one we never really had a
company in a garage
all we did was we once once a week we'd
pick up a bunch of pre-made apple one
type boards we'd bring into the garage
test them and see what worked i was the
one who taught everyone here's how you
test them and here's how to fix them
and then they'd get driven to the store
that paid cash but we never had desks in
the garage we never had more than about
one or two people in the garage uh
rarely ever used the garage but it
represents
the humility of our start the humbleness
we had nothing you've got to use your
home when you're young if you look at
the the 10 first people that contributed
to the design of the apple ii computer
some of them went to the same high
school
that's just how it is you go with your
friends yeah when you made that first
computer
you knew right away like
i just changed the world or was it kind
of like this is fun for me no i knew it
was so far ahead of what everyone else
was trying yeah and it was going to show
the world a whole new way i knew that
i didn't want to take any credit for it
i didn't want any money for it didn't
want a company didn't want to start an
industry necessarily
just discreetly among the others and
then the apple ii was really
knew that would be a big company
successful company the apple one was
just quickly modified from a different
product you know into into a computer
but the apple ii was the big one like i
said that was to all the revenues apple
for the first 10 years of the company
our only successful product we failed
with the apple iii we failed with the
lisa we failed with the macintosh and in
that moment
could you have ever predicted something
like the iphone where like it's all that
power in a in your pocket
there were no cell phones yet
of any type not even analog cell phones
and the amount of memory that would hold
a song
cost close to a million dollars well you
think we're thinking of you'll have a
little device in your hand with a
thousand songs or a chip that holds 500
movies no moore's law says you'll get
there right but you don't know when
moore's law is going to end and you
don't know the path that it's going to
get what's moore's law moore's law is is
what makes silicon valley silicon valley
they started out building the transistor
it's the electronic neuron
and
and everything you own in your life
that's electronic uses transistors
everything digital uses transistors as i
said now they make one chip for with 60
billion transistors on it for apple but
they used to build one transistor at a
time not 60 billion at a time and the
inventor of the transistor moved to
mountain view california started
shockley labs hired a bunch of engineers
taught them how transistor mathematics
would work the physics behind the the
parts silicon and little other atoms in
there and then some of them left to
start another
transistor company called fairchild and
the fairchild had spin-offs eventually
and then somebody i went to a show once
when i was eight years old and this guy
held up a big
a a
big piece of cardboard with things like
houses on it and streets connecting them
and he said this is a chip we're gonna
make that'll have six transistors on one
chip
might have been gordon moore you know or
bob noyce this is the founders of intel
and i'm i and i saw that oh my gosh i
thought now i'm gonna have a better six
transistor radio but new technologies
cost too much for that for people to
really take advantage of and um and
silicon valley sort of grew because
what led to the big economy boost of the
world
over the over some period of time
decades was
the rise in in technical equipment what
it could do what it could do because
every year moore's law said you'd have
more transistors on a chip for the same
price every year you'd have more than
before and just rows and rows and rows
we didn't know how far it would go but
that's what got us here yeah is it that
it would like double or more was the guy
putting the transistors on the chip
um he was a founder of intel
and he came up with this law after
observing sever many years of it growing
at a certain rate how many transitions
was like double the number of
transistors every 18 months something
like that yeah got it but
where does it end for like even society
it's still going on a little bit but
it's slowed down a lot because you get
to you get down to modifying one atom at
a time you can't go any further we're
down you know kind of close to that
so we're not really um
you know the only way to make chip chip
with more transistors make a bigger chip
now you can't do it in the same size as
well we're just about at the the end and
the end of what moore's law brings us
but it's
it's not really changing the sort of uh
iphones we can make every year but is it
the metaverse is next
metaverse is is intriguing uh i hate i
even i i'm not gonna go to um facebook's
metaphors but there's meta verses and
it's kind of like what they call it
second world
back when people could build their own
properties and sell them for real cash
and all that and that'll happen but i
love um the idea
of the of the real geeks the solid geeks
that just want to live 24 7 inside their
goggles and deal with people that way i
mean ready player one
ready player one that's what happens
scott says this to me every single day
he's like i don't get it i'm like ready
player one it's not for everybody maybe
but it's for deep geeks that i was i
feel like oh go ahead are there going to
be music festivals in the metaverse
yes there are let me give you an example
um for virtual reality
you know and i get in that it's just oh
my god so amazing it's like you are
there emotions tell you what products
will succeed but then i saw a live
basketball game live you know and you
the players go run in front of you and
you'd be turning your head i saw a
football game that way and you'd be
under the basket and they dunk it right
downtown oh the emotions and then i saw
a coldplay at a at a concert in chicago
on vr
my gosh and the camera's moving right
around on the stage you're you're seeing
so much more than just a concert that
i'm for that yeah and i think concerts
will be real real plentiful in um
in a metaverse here's a problem with the
metaverse bandwidth
how can we do it
you can put on goggles and be in an
artificial reality and it looks really
good high resolution
but a high resolution camera is kind of
narrow you know focus you'd have to take
10 of those around your head and then
you have to take 10 of them this way
that's 100 times the resolution just to
get the resolution you want
okay
so maybe only do a hemisphere 50 times
we need a lot of resolution to make it
look like it's a real world able to
change that fast like it's real i've you
know done i've done a few demos like
that and it's very impressive so moore's
law does have a little ways to go
maybe it's still we're still finding
tricks like instead of building
transistors horizontally across this way
we're building them vertically and yeah
little tricks that pack them in tighter
yeah i wanted to ask about music
festivals in the metaverse because i
wanted to hear you talk about your music
festival
yeah the us festival
okay i had all this
wealth from apple that i didn't ever
want i didn't seek it
and i could give enough away to museums
that started up in san jose and in the
street after me but i'm just thinking i
um i had an airplane crash and after
five weeks of amnesia where i wasn't
forming memories
i came out of it and realized oh my gosh
i haven't been forming memories nobody
around me had
realized that so i called up steve jobs
and said this is the last chance in my
life 10 years after my third year of
college my last chance to go back for a
year college and finish it
and
so my name was famous so i went back to
berkeley under a fake name my diploma
says rocky raccoon clark
because you know you should laugh
everything in life should have a fun
element i love it and but around that
time i thought my gosh what could i do
with all this wealth that you know would
be interesting to me and what music
festivals had meant to me as an attendee
in my life some huge ones in the bay
area and ones in the fillmore and uh
and then there was the movie woodstock
if i'd read the book
barefoot in babylon about how they put
woodstock together if i'd read it two
weeks before i never would have invested
yeah in doing a festival and i did the
us festival and it was um three great
days we planned that we took care of
everything all the the parking we spent
10 million dollars just creating an
amphitheater that could fit 500 000
people and it was successful from one
point of view if everyone liked it i
said you know whoever however many
porta-potties is normal twice as much it
was going to be a you know a come-off
good for the attendees
but lost a lot of money and then a big
eight accounting firm said we lost money
because of cheaters that were getting
under fences
so next year we we made sure that it was
tighter security and this next year we
would have photographs of the crowd to
do count you know counting the number of
people plus we'd have the ticket turn
still counts and we'd have the ticket
stubs we'd have three different how many
were sold we'd match them all up and it
turns out that the press was just wrong
they were exaggerating how many people
were really there but man it was so
wonderful and it was really the format
that showed there's a huge interest this
was in the la area san bernardino a huge
interest in uh three-day festivals you
just got to do it right find the formula
to make money so now we've got uh you
know bonnaroo came around
on
wow
when you had the plane crash would that
have counted as a near-death experience
no the plane crash we all we all
survived
i i'm the only one who didn't have a
plane crash that was in the plane
because
i can remember everything that day from
landing at um
skyport airport or whatever was in um
in scotts valley and i can remember
going around and having it around an
obstacle picking up two more passengers
going for i can remember right up to
reaching for the throttle and after that
you press it and i had no memories of
pressing the throttle
and when i studied psychology and memory
i found out that memories have to sit in
your short-term memory for a little
while to get made permanent
and if you get hit
hard in a crash
airplane and car crashes
that very often the memories that hadn't
sat there for 30 seconds are lost they
never get made so i have no memories of
an actual plane crash
and five weeks
five weeks had gone by i wouldn't know
it i don't know any time it passed by
and
and i met somebody macintosh somebody i
guess my wife took me down to the
macintosh group and my good friend andy
herzfeld said something about a plane
crash as soon as he said that i said i'm
in the plane crash dream when you're in
a dream you can turn around and walk the
other way and i almost did it almost did
i sat there and said i'll play by the
rules of the dream i talked to him later
that night i asked my fiancee did i have
a plane crash or was it a dream
and she said steve it was a dream
because i joke so much
you know i make up phony stories
everybody i had to know i had a plane
crash but i didn't wow and so she said
it was it was a dream i felt my body in
bed i couldn't feel anything disturbed i
didn't feel where i was missing a tooth
for five weeks i didn't know my dog was
in a kennel for five weeks i would never
ever
have done that and then i woke up and
all of a sudden half my brain was now
forming memories and realized they had
been stalked before that in the other
half
that got my interest quite a bit and
then i found a hundred cards on the bed
stand from all the closest people in my
life that had sent me well wishing after
a plane crash i didn't know they were
there but i must have passed them every
day and night getting in and out of bed
they were there and i went looked at
them over and contacted some of the
people now that was a uh
um so that was a big deal but i i'm glad
for the plane crash in the end because
it got me to do the music festival right
i asked them because they're you hear
stories about people who have near-death
experiences and when they come out of it
they uh their priorities are are
sort of restructured and once in a while
but um
my personality didn't change right and
not only that but they also talked about
having seen their life go by before one
of my psychology professors at berkeley
um you know
was talked about his experience in the
ocean and he had gone under and saw his
life experiences go by and somehow they
saved them
but so that's that so that's probably
real but how would i remember it
i might have gone through it and
remember had all my life flashing before
me but i can't remember it right
so um
right so that was uh plane crash i'm
thankful it got me to berkeley it got me
to my degree you know i have a real
degree and i've been made a lie of the
years the guy raccoon guy has a degree
yeah rocky raccoon
alumni of the year and they have like
you know dozens of nobel prize winners
on the staff there berkeley so that was
really precious to me and i was
engineering alumni once of the year so
i love that do you have a favorite prank
like the
the coup de gras no so many pranks
unbelievable and some of the best ones
with steve jobs it didn't quite come off
but we we did all the work to do them
but they got disturbed did you ever
think about adding a prank inside one of
the computers like some kind of you know
easter egg many times i played i even
taught um computers to elementary middle
school kids for eight years i taught
them how to do pranks i taught them even
how to crack passwords of a computer you
know
and it was a long process you know go
down and you know
set up a password on your computer
and then go change your password and see
what parts what bytes in memory change
find those and then start changing a b c
d here on the and figure out what the
scheme is and the scheme was just not
even encryption it was just a cipher you
know an a became an n and a b became a
cue it was that simple so they would go
to school and
get access
just by looking at the code you can find
where you find where it is and then you
find how to how to read it and what it
what it is or change it to something you
want sure amazing but i mean a little
bit a little bit of hacking but for good
don't hurt anybody i have a question
about like looking towards the future
with technology because like to me with
the metaverse it's fascinating it's
exciting but it's sort of an extension
of what we're already doing a little bit
vr has existed it's kind of like it's
video games it's entertainment
but to me like do you have an opinion
about like the neural link or things
like this where like our brains would be
connected uh like through
technology
like elon musk talks about it and stuff
i haven't heard anything that's going to
be important to people
any of that kind of stuff neural links
and and think certain thoughts and steer
steer a car kind of so slow it can't
really work into real life i i haven't
bought into any of that um in the fut
everything that bothers me these days
i'm very negative pessimistic about
technology because so many things
that i think i have i don't own anymore
and they change they change so
drastically i can't even operate them
our tesla out there is a good example
and then oh it would i'd have a
different way to it they changed the way
to it by voice if the voice button on
the steering wheel worked but i've been
waiting two months for service no i just
hate everything's called artificial
intelligence it's artificial all right
but it's not intelligence like a brain
it's just figuring out a few little
formulas okay if you usually go um buy
some milk on wednesday it's wednesday
we'll notify you to go buy some milk uh
so many times when it's not what you
want to do that wednesday you're in a
different city you know they're just
they're just interruptions in your life
just like spam
and i really and a lot of the old school
ways i stick with old school email i
don't do the the social web and
um
maybe it's because that's where i
started but and when you give somebody
your card it's your actual email
yes
email address i made a rule when i was
young remember when i was 20 years old
one of the rules in my life about being
was that these executives hide out and
they always say in articles we couldn't
get a hold of so and so to ask them a
question about it
and i did not want to be
um
that i didn't want to be that person i
said i'd always have a listed phone
number always in my life and this is an
extension of that that yeah if i'm going
to give out some data it should be real
truth is the highest to me so here i've
got four cards for three cards for the
three of you oh my gosh now these cards
have have 911 history i don't know if
you've heard it
but after 9 11 you'd get on an airplane
after 9 11 you'd get on an airplane
and they would wouldn't give you a metal
knife they'd give you a plastic knife
and it would break off cutting steak you
know which i liked so i made these cards
and i'd go on the planes and i would
just slice those steaks so clean and
smooth and the flight attendants would
say oh a metal business card it wasn't
on a list like a knife right but it
serves the purpose
wow and it's so good thank you for this
i can't believe it yeah that's true this
is the third generation second
generation was my favorite i should have
brought you some of those but because i
made a punched card like the old punch
card days
hollerith format it's called and i put
my phone number on the punch card
and it was really boring on the punch
card because my phone number's too
boring but um
but but the trouble is nobody i didn't
print it so nobody knew that's a phone
number you know right i'd be anxious
like when we had our dogs our dog letter
in our house we had six were born
and janet numbered each one of them with
nail polish but she used the color of
resistor color codes
from the old electronic days okay so a
one is brown and a two is red so when
the mother licks it off a lot you
sometimes can't read the letter but you
can see the color
yeah so we numbered our dogs because i
wanted to know which one was born before
the others because you see the movie
clueless
yes and where she says
um what's her name
i forget her the actress yes
no but no the character
but she says her partner cleo or
something like that but she says okay
asked her when she was born she said i
was born a month earlier and as a you
know more knowledgeable superior to you
i wanted to be always safe what was the
order because we had bought two dogs to
start with and we don't know which was
born first
wow you know i mean life is those are
the important things in life
you know not the all the business
solutions and right what you're uh
the companies you're involved with now
are isn't it like quite a few
and and a lot of that is to use business
solutions to really help real world
issues
it's not thought out that way business
opportunities approach me maybe a dozen
a day sometimes at least one every day
will you join me we join our company
will you be on our board of advisors
whatever they want my name and
i i'm only one person i don't have a
staff i don't have i don't have money i
gave that away a long time ago and i
just have to it's bothers me the number
of times i have to say no then they
still come back again you have to say no
more
and hide from them a little um
so
that's i get hit a lot
once in a while you know i used to meet
people more often maybe once a week i'd
go out to a lunch and hear what they're
up and just say that's really sounds
good you know i'm not a part of it i
don't want to get into anything new i
have a busy life and then one time i sat
down and they started talking about
solid state discs
do you all know what solid state disks
are
they're they're chips and they're faster
than the hard disks that were made of
atoms spin around they use electrons in
the solid state disks and everybody was
starting to talk about it and this one
company they had instead of building a
solid-state disk that you connect where
it disconnects
they had a board that plugs right into
the slots in the computer you're getting
about the eight slots in the application
plugs right into the slot in the
computer
and then has software
that makes it perform like a disk
and because of that you can write better
software that makes it have more data
and run faster than all these other
approaches to disk drives that have to
use a standard connector that goes at a
certain standard speed
and this company had designed things the
way i thought as a designer when i
designed stuff for apple
and i was offered a chance to join them
and i said yes
that was fusion io they went big and
successful as fast and important as
apple
when they did they changed the whole
world they were just starting you know
you're starting out in a you know a one
gigabyte
a solid state disk at first cost twenty
thousand dollars
you know we're up to terabytes now for
hundreds of dollars in solid state disk
one terabyte for 170 bucks today i mean
um
so that was a great company i was so
glad to be a part of that because they
were changing the world yeah yeah and i
didn't really make a lot from it the
founders made you know
a couple hundred million each but then
they each divorced their mormon wives of
salt lake city and
but i didn't think these mormons with
their type families that i would have
dinners with that would ever you know be
in that divorce category
so um that was fusion io now more
recently there was a group that
approached me
and what they do is they look at ways
you can make electricity costs more
efficient go into a big company a big
factory and change lights and change air
conditioners and and do other things and
make it use less electricity
and then they would collect a portion of
the savings but they would have to
finance it themselves they'd have to go
in do all the installations of the
materials and they became they were
making tens and hundreds of millions of
dollars a year for like six years this
is an ongoing successful company that
has a formula they're real people and
crypto was starting up
and i talked to them for two years it
took them to talk me into joining them
as i liked what they did but we what we
what they made they made it really
interesting we're going to have a crypto
coin on an exchange they wound up naming
it was x
and it's on exchange in malta and a
couple other places and then people can
buy in and the blockchain tracks
everything from turning on a light
switch to all the costs involved in the
savings and you get part of the savings
right in the blockchain you is the
investor in it and that's called force
e-f-f-o-r-c-e and i really love what uh
what it's what it's all about it's all
about energy efficiency i was about that
my whole life yeah and then we got the
space company uh started by a really
good friend of mine that he always has
business thinking so far beyond me and
thinking about all the sub markets and
who you can approach for things and
raising money uh has done incredible
with his last company ripcord they're
gonna go public next year probably you
know for a couple of trillion i don't
know i sold this ft at one point and
people were getting mad at me they were
barking at me about energy being wasted
with nft
so is this energy-saving solution well
even bitcoin
you know gold of all it's only
mathematical no human can control
bitcoin and the amounts of it and
anything
that's um it takes a lot of a lot of
energy to mine it to create to keep
bitcoin to keep these all the cyber
currencies and nfts going um
but it costs amount of energy for
whatever anything is worth
right because the costs the economy
three e's the economy equals the energy
used equals the emissions mean pollution
okay and that's a formula never here
anywhere else sounds as easy as as um
equals mc squared for einstein right
it's that easy
the global economy gnp say equals the
amount of energy that was used if you
double one you double the other
and that equals the amount of pollution
that we get
double the energy you'll double the
pollution the only the only way to to
really solve this uh
climate problem is
take our lives way way back down in
economy
take them way back down so i don't buy
into a lot of you know people thinking
let's do this one little step you know
buy an electric car or get a solar panel
that it actually makes any difference at
all it can actually go the opposite way
just like the bitcoin mining but you
know everything we got in life um a
house a car this rv is beautiful
do you think the world's
going towards crypto or you think we'll
always stick with fiat
it's hard to erase things that humans
have learned and can put into books
methods of doing it some countries have
even disallowed crypto on blockchain
technologies it can be used a lot i
think it's being used a lot these days
to rip people off
i'll start a crypto i'll hire an
engineer that knows how to create it and
i'll get a celebrity to back it up you
know and we'll put out the um
the kim coin kim kardashian or something
like that that's probably a bad example
but um it's a great example it's a great
example it is it's a really good one
okay because i don't do social websites
i don't really know how to know the
names to use but we'll call and i see
that happening all the time and then the
founders that started it pull off some
millions of dollars right away from
investors that say i want to get in
quick and early when it's young because
it's gonna grow like bitcoin i'll make a
billion out of out of pennies
and they jump in and then it goes to
zero that's the common story it's not
the only story there's some others that
are that made it for a while for
some good reasons yeah so i'm kind of
nfts fall into that category too the
number of people getting ripped off on
crypto and nfts is just just outrageous
now bitcoin is safe because it's the big
elephant on the block it's stable right
like conservative conservative thinking
you go for the big ones and they'll be
around and um
yeah bitcoin is uh this is you uh stable
so i don't invest
i don't i have never invested in stock
in my life i've never used apple stock
app on the iphone
ever because why
it goes to my happiness formula i found
that my head gets to a peaceful spot
where it's not worrying about everything
being up and down up and down up and
down like day traders i had traders
around me and i watched what they went
through and i just turned the other way
i don't read any financial papers i
don't want to be
you know i don't want that to affect my
life so i never invested in stocks um
bitcoin i bought a bunch of bitcoin at
the start to say how do you play with
this new thing how do you buy something
online and i conquered that and how do
you buy things in other countries and
how would you even pay for like a donut
in another country how can you find an
atm that works on your bitcoin and i
want to experiment and learn it all
and then bitcoin went way up well i got
scared and i sold all my bitcoin except
one bitcoin i had that's not my purpose
is to have enough to play with and
experiment with but not to make money on
and two times it's gone way up and made
money and just recently i think bitcoin
is going to go to a hundred thousand i
just you know i don't know where you get
that feeling i can't put any uh
mathematics to it i just really feel it
from all of the interest the interesting
crypto is so high and so i
put a put a bunch of money into uh
um
into
an online wallet account coinbase
and pretty much it's sitting right where
it was right now went way up it doubled
and then it halved again and you know
that's but that's not my way in life i'm
just that's not important to me when you
had a ton of money did your
did you get less happy and then you gave
it away and you got more happy or never
i saw so many people i never changed the
way i was i
gave my money to so many good things
they have a street named after me in san
jose and then
a friend another a hacker friend kevin
mitnick
okay his fame he's got some great books
i write the four words for him and uh he
was calling me like at two in the
morning i'm in moscow russia he'd call
me four in the morning i'm in in bogota
colombia
and all these places and i said that's
kind of intriguing that you get to all
these places speaking
he was speaking so he had we had a
dinner in san francisco with a speech
agent from boston and she said she could
get me speeches
you know and i was ready to get a new
new occupation oh you know rather than
starting companies i could always get
involved in company startups
and i said yeah and that's where it
started you know and and i went i've
done it for 15 years and i've risen to
the top
i have risen to the top i got up to
where i was doing 100 speeches a year
most of them foreign okay that meant a
lot of long airplane flights i don't get
to choose a nice set of cities like a
rock group we'll go all the cities along
california from north no i don't get to
do that it's where the speech offers
come in
and uh i've been to all the exotic
countries almost all the exotic
countries
you know the saudi arabias and moscows
and china and
um all
a lot of a lot of strange places some
small places super cool
that's my occupation and i've gotten so
good at it i've been able to support my
family
two questions do you know how many
countries you've been to no
never counted we made a list sometimes
for we were trying to get a um
biocitizenship
in grenada we got it took a year and a
half of work figuring out what countries
i've been in
huh in your in ten years
i don't remember how many it was like 80
countries maybe oh you got us maybe a
hundred
no
we're both sitting around
i think you reached out to me one time
asking if i wanted to go to antarctica
with you that was the best trip of our
life we love we like to take places we
like to take cruises
cruises seabourn cruise ship will give
us a cruise for a speech on board and we
went to antarctica
that was the drive to drive bombers it
was like a project oh no the the the
hammer one was um there's a guy that had
project a couple times he took land
rovers and did trips driving around the
world it was called
drive around the world dot com d-a-t-v
we w and he went to all little countries
i've never been to bhutan and places
like that you can't really get into a
risk getting caught or something right
and so they wanted to do that and drive
on this new road they built in
antarctica that goes to the south pole
drive it but getting all the support
that you would need to you know be
covered that they would come out and
rescue if you needed um it never quite
that one never came off right tried to
get the science companies into it but
i could have been there janet i got on a
cruise to antarctica
like it's best cruise in the world yeah
the best thing you could ever do yeah
you could have been good on that and
buzz aldrin was on there right right we
actually filmed some early scenes in
modified hummers we're going to modify
we got modified some yammers with huge
type track wheels that can
do just like this
electric but you can't do that in
antarctica where you're gonna get your
electricity just like the apple store
there's no way i would have turned down
an opportunity to drive hummers through
antarctica with steve wozniak okay
i i i well i eventually i got less
favorable towards it because it was
taking so long
and they just were ideas and ideas and i
didn't want to be involved the promotion
much and buzz aldrin also kind of
dropped out of it
so it's probably not ever going to come
off but they did a lot of work a lot of
work in preparation from their studies
of driving
gas cars you know around the world trips
kind of huge huge driving
man
can you uh uh talk about the box
oh yeah let me
see thank you
you came in with this box yeah yeah wait
let's hold it right there just so i can
pee i'm dying a piece does anybody have
to take a bathroom break
no we can't stop now sit down
just kidding
[Laughter]
alrighty the box let's do the box
[Music]
okay
lots of things in here
i'll put that down for now
first of all
there's there's a printer in this town
of los gatos
that makes these pads for me
pads of two dollar bills they really
smell the ink yeah you can still smell
like they're freshly printed
they're not real are they well hold on
he gets the supplies from a higher
quality printer
and they meet the specs of the us
government these bills and because they
meet the specs of the us government i've
looked it up they are legal tender i've
been spending them for like 30 years and
um i mean i don't know if it's the right
president
they want to get ink on me but um no
it's great and i sell a sheet of four
two dollar bills for five dollars
everywhere i go i sell lots of them and
because it don't cost me eight dollars
for a sheet
and they're legal the secret service has
approved them i've had police called on
me a number of times the secret service
approved these bills
three times two of the times they
actually saw the bills
i don't know why it's only two times and
one time they read me my miranda rights
and when they read me my miranda rights
i should have brought it with me i used
um a fake id that i made from back when
a personal computer could not print a
photo
could not print photo quality unless you
owned a real expensive dye sublimation
printer
to make backstage passes and all so i
have this i have this the id that i gave
the secret service says department of
defense but i respelled it defiant so i
could say it's a joke
not a not a fraud card
and it says i'm a laser safety officer
and i have an eye patch in the picture
laser safety officer that's what i gave
the secret service when they they knew
these bills were good they tested them
with the pen they'll pass the test so
you'll probably
want these i know steve has them but
i'll leave a few sheets here oh my god
oh look at that and if you look at the
serial number of this top one here it
ends you know two six five
um but they're the legal tender the
secret service is in charge of
counterfeit money
unreal who can i show this on camera wow
of course you can smell it everything i
said is true except the president i know
it is the right president
um
it's amazing well
yeah looks great
all righty
unreal my game boy
my game boy now they never sold this
model in the united states it's from the
original original game boys with the
original original tetris cartridge
and this game boy lights up
it actually lights up
it was only sold in japan it was called
game boy light
and i still play tetris on it regularly
to just pass time when i want to
and one time i used to have always have
the high score on game boy tetris and
i'd send it into nintendo power magazine
back when you had to take real photos
and send them in the paper mail and they
said oh we your name's always in there
we want you we don't want to print it
anymore we're not going to print your
name anymore because we want new people
to get on the list
oh so i i did i took a picture of a high
score and i spelled my name steve
backwards is evans and wozniak backwards
is kane zou
evitz kanezow
and then i thought if i put los gatos
they'll get suspicious it's the same guy
so i put saratoga california the next
city over and i sent it in and then i
forgot about it and i picked up this
nintendo power magazine
um one day and i flipped back to where
they have the scores and it's in here
but it prints that name everett's keynes
out and i saw it i didn't know it was
mine i'd forgotten i'd done it i said oh
my god a foreigner and he said saratoga
i got chilled he's nearby
and then and then i remember doing it
but so my name backwards is actually in
that magazine so you're still ranked for
your tetris score yes wow
well it was it was the highest that was
ever printed in nintendo power magazine
i don't play it anymore there's people
better than me i'm sure i don't know um
the highest one i ever got i didn't send
into the later years i think it was
30 6300 something like that my goal was
750 but never i'll never hit it
now this is a great mask of course
because everywhere i go this is the
number one mask everyone says oh i like
your mask i like your mask you know they
never do that every single place you go
so on airplanes i'd like to put this n95
over it
and then i'll
oh
it's a little tight i'll call a flight
attendant and i'll say
i want to inform you that for the rest
of this flight i'm going to take this
mask off
and and at first they're shocked and
kind of accusing me you know and then
they laugh
so laughter laughter is really worth it
you know now i used to go into janet and
i for quite a while wore
this type of face mask
hang on it might be trapped this type of
face mask
with a hepa filter
that you could wear you could wear on
the lanyard
that's great so you'd wear it you'd wear
it and you can turn it on to three
blowing levels
okay so sometimes when we're going to
the cigarette smoke or something jeff
janet's asthmatic this is a nice way to
get fresh air fresh air through a
through a fan that's in here
and when i go into the stores like the
grocery store
um i would tell people a normal mask
isn't adequate for my condition
and i said what's your condition i'd say
geekiness
this this mask i've worn a couple of
times during the mask days
with something under
i love this mask
wow it's also for geekiness
now we've got another type of peppa mask
hepa filter mask right here that just
goes on you
and it's also
filtered
yeah it's smaller and and you got
buttons for like a bane from batman now
during the the black lives matter
protest i thought if i ever heard of a
protest around here i might want to get
in it so i actually bought a real gas
mask too but i never used this in public
to say this is my this is my mask but i
could
that takes care of my box wow that's so
great yeah
steve and i always joke about with the
time we got dinner and they came over
with the pepper and he said course and
then when they were done he said fine
i think about that once a week that's
amazing because just last night we went
out to dinner with
i don't know uh oh a friend a friend
from the masons i'm an honorary
california freemason for life wow i'm a
life member i'm not a mason as a person
is there a secret handshake not but i
went through a whole bunch of things
because my wife at the time was an
eastern star and then we could have more
joint time together
is there there are secret words you have
to learn that i have no idea what i can
know you can never remember them it's
very difficult then you go up three
levels you're a mason for life and
everyone goes up to 33 levels not me i
dropped out because we got divorced
yeah and you probably played some tricks
on them but we were we were at the
restaurant yesterday the old spaghetti
factory
they brought up pepper and i did the
whole the standard thing or maybe it was
the night before somewhere and i said of
course
and then that's fine
whoever it was
it was actually at the grill on the
alley steakhouse and they were they were
actually kind of pleased with
the joke
fantastic and because i do like coarse
pepper
you know that's fine when i said of
course of course she unscrewed it to
make it coarse she realized she realized
it was more than just saying yeah sure
wow
i gotta say that every time i've ever
gotten together with you has just been
the most fantastic experience i value
our friendship beyond measure
yes and i decide the same absolutely
i'm a person that makes very very few
friends in my life you know every few
years i might make another one
that'll be a long-term friend
continually it's very rare
yeah well
you're in there you're the one i'm
absolutely beyond grateful for you and
uh and and this time like like always
was very special and the fact that we
were able to record it and share it with
the world is even more so so thank you
the key people in my life are creative
people
and also especially comedians
magicians and the fact that you came to
my bucket list show and and actually
made it through to the end i i i oh no
no i understand comedy i was not against
that i was not disfavorable that's what
you that's what you do that's your
business oh no no i understood it i told
julie that she said that you thought
that somehow i was offended by it no no
i was just scared that you were gonna
see the things that i show at my bucket
list oh you gave me some no we took out
some really straight friends and i
started describing exactly what you've
done
oh wow man i love you steve and uh thank
you for this really looking forward to
the next time is there anything that we
can promote for you do you want to send
any traffic anywhere i i never do i
never try to promote myself for anything
he's like world peace yeah world beast i
probably did the rescue rescue a dog and
what is that mask where's that face mask
oh the selfie mask
mask
makes the best ones i don't get anything
to a mask i like maska-like dolls don't
make a mask that looks like your face
that looks like your face you can also
buy ones that look like dogs and stuff
sure i have some of those i want a steve
wozniak mask okay that's upside down oh
well that would be a steve wozniak mask
if it were right side up
and i've ordered it i like dot com yeah
i think a couple more are getting
delivered to our house in a day or two i
love it it's fantastic yeah it's
fantastic and i've only been wearing it
for like three weeks yeah at every every
single place people say oh i like your
mask yeah well you said it okay
well
bless you steve and thank thank you so
much for this
yeah everybody go to go get something
that matters home now
there you go
and there it is folks can you even
believe it dude i mean
he said he makes a friend every few
years and i'm one of his friends
and dude
he sat there and talked with us for like
an hour and 20 minutes man
he he came out to see my show on tour he
watched me ejaculate as i fell out of an
airplane butt naked with a dude strapped
in my back
and then he told me that he enjoyed it
okay
i i'm beside myself this dude really is
the most
he's had the single
most
impact on
the future of the human race out of
anybody who's lived
god damn
thank you for watching